قصه نجاح يسجلها اليمن هذه المره من
واشنطن مع استعاده حوالي 80 قطعه اثريه
منهوبه ومهربه الى الولايات المتحده
الاعلان عن هذا الانجاز اتى في حفل اقيم
على شرف الجهات التي عملت على رصد هذه
القطع ومصادرتها السفير اليمني في
الولايات المتحده محمد الحضرمي اعرب عن
امتنانه الشديد للجهود الامريكيه التي
افضت الى استعاده هذه القطع الشاهده على
تاريخ وتراث اليمن العريق كلنا ان شاء
الله سنعمل في المستقبل القريب خلال
اسابيع على التوقيع على
مذكره تفاهم مع الخارجيه الامريكيه لضمان
استمرار هذا العمل وهو عدم سرقه الاثار
اليمنيه وان تم سرقتها ترصدها واعادتها
الى الشعب اليمني
فخر الولايات المتحده سلمت السلطات
اليمنيه 64 راسا حجريا منحوتا و11
مخطوطه من المصحف ووعاء منقوشا من البرونز
وشاهد جنائزيه من ثقافات معين في مرتفعات
شمال غرب اليمن ويرجع تاريخها الى القرن
الاول قبل الميلاد
هذه قطع يمنيه من التراث اليمني هو حقيقه
ان العديد من الوكالات والمنظمات المختلفه
كان عليها التعاون معا لتحقيق ذلك وجميعهم
ممثلون هنا اليوم ويمكن ان نرى المحيط
الذي يشعر به الناس فاغلبيتهم لم يزولوا
اليمن ولكنهم يطوقون الى التعرف على
الحضاره اليمنيه
الحكومه اليمنيه ستسمح لمتحف سميثونيوم في
واشنطن بالاحتفاظ بهذه القطع لمده عامين
بموجب اتفاق موقع بين الطرفين يسمح
بالمحافظه على هذه القطع من جهه وبالترويج
لليمن الغني بثقافته والحضارات التي
تعاقبت على ارضه
طريق طويل سلكتها هذه الاثار حتى استعادها
اليمن من جديد عينه صغيره من مئات القطع
الاثريه التي تحاول الحكومه استعادتها بعد
نهبها وتهريبها خارج البلاد
لتسليمان العربيه واشنطن